so your book the Hollywood game plan
okay so you've written a lot of things
on you know how people can kind of get
their foot in the door and thank you
notes and useful information I want to
talk about this over 40 population right
maybe they're new to the industry right
I'm here from somewhere else or another
line of work right let's talk about do
those same rules apply and what is
working for a person over 40 what is
working against them how to fight that
that is a good question
ageism totally exists in this business
to say it doesn't would be to say a lie
however the way you can protect yourself
against it is with your material there's
two things one is having great material
that's undeniable people don't care if
it's again I'm thinking about
screenwriters let's say if it's on the
page it doesn't matter if the other
thing is to stay contemporary if you
don't know what read it is or what
LinkedIn or I can't imagine anybody
doesn't know what Twitter is but if you
don't know what's happening then that
ages you I've told a lot of writers who
are over 40 make a webseries show that
you know what's going on and show and
it's a way to make you undeniable also
there's a lot of people ageism is there
but there's a lot of people that say
we're looking for somebody who has some
life experience I'm not looking for
somebody who just got out of USC who
made three student films has had no life
and is only consumed entertainment and
doesn't have any life experience so I
don't believe that I think the only
person that is going to get in the way
is you if you're thinking I'm too old if
your material is there if you're a
contemporary with what's going on in the
business and the trends in the society I
don't think it's gonna be a problem
all right so then look at the headlines
that research what companies are doing
well what's the latest social media you
know the app or you know do because for
me like snapchat I'm still learning
about it I don't really know and I feel
like that dates me you know yeah cuz so
many people that are under 25 they're
all about snapchat right and so there's
a demographic there's a population that
I don't know about that I don't know how
to work it and all the things that are
part of it let's say somebody wants to
get even just an entry level on mailroom
position or administrative assistant or
receptionist being 40 it's hard to be
tougher it's gonna be tougher I know one
guy who was a lawyer but all he wanted
to do was be a writer and he ended up
getting a job as the assistant to the
showrunner on SVU and he did that for
two years he was the most overqualified
assistant that ever existed and then he
got a job as a staff writer and he was
in his 40s it is very hard to get a
entry-level job what I recommend that
people do if somebody just emailed me
and said what can I do I want to be an
executive I'm 48 and I said be a
producer first have a body of work under
your belt come in with material come in
showing that you can produce work but I
think it's really hard unless you've
been a professional administrative
assistant to get a job as an
administrative assistant when you're
over 40 it's not impossible because some
people don't care but it's more
challenging it's definitely more
challenging well not to advocate lying
on a resume but do you leave off let's
suppose oh I have so much work
experience to show them they're
definitely going to want to hire me
maybe that works against you it does
work against you don't go back more than
10 years I definitely tell my clients
they don't need to see anything from
2002 absolutely not and what I also tell
my clients is tell me how old you really
are and then if they're over a certain
age I say don't tell anybody
interesting absolutely get to know who
workers sorry even if they get to know
if you get to know co-workers and your
clothes you can but actually I keep it
pretty close to the vest interesting
well yes I've known people for years I
have no idea what their ages I never
asked right but then some people are
much more free you think running free
with it hurts you I wouldn't be free
with it if you are older than most of
the people you're working with
I wouldn't sling that around no I would
I just wouldn't make a deal of it
right okay
you